.
ERNIE JOHNSON WITH SHAQUILLE
O'NEAL, KENNY "THE JET" SMITH,
AND CHARLES BARKLEY.
OFF THE BAT THE SERIES TOOK A
TURN.
YOU'RE INTO THE OPENING SECONDS
OF THE GAME WHEN JAMES HARDEN
GOES TO THE HOLE AND COMES DOWN
GRIPPING THAT RIGHT HAMSTRING.
INJURY THAT HAD PUT HIM ON THE
SHELF FOR 21 GAMES LATE IN THE
YEAR.
AND HE DID NOT RETURN.
SO IN THE LAST WORD WE GOT, HE
WAS HEADED FOR AN MRI AND SO HAS
LEFT THE BUILDING, HEADED FOR AN
MRI.
SO WE WILL SEE WHAT THAT IS.
>> IT'S THE EXACT SAME SITUATION
WITH THE LAKERS.
>> WITH THE LAKERS?
>> YEAH.
WITH LeBRON AND A.D.
ERNIE, YOU CAN'T NOT JUST SHOW
UP FOR THE PLAYOFFS.
YOU HAVE TO PLAY BASKETBALL TO
GET IN SHAPE.
YOU CAN GO A STRETCH IF YOU HAD
LEG INJURIES BUT THE PLAYOFFS
ARE SO GRUELING BECAUSE YOU'RE
PLAYING EVERY OTHER DAY.
LIKE --
>> THE INTENSITY.
>> EXCUSE ME?
OO.
>> AND THE INTENSITY.
>> IF YOU'RE SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES, YOU CAN'T DO ANY
CONDITIONING.
>> PLA